这是一条完全有AI生成的母亲节广告, 超过20多万人看过, 我是如何制作的呢
上期说了点单多的话给大家录一期细节, 这种内容放到街上那开个课随便卖你2万, 希望能够帮助到各位品牌方和创作者, 需要看成片效果的可以直接拉到三分钟以后, 直接给大家省干货
上期节目已经说了我的流程, 写脚本, 深图, 深视频, 深音乐, 剪辑合成, 其中花时间最多的其实是写脚本
第一回答一下大家我用的什么工具, 我说过我用的是画布, 实际上就是想告诉大家
你用哪家AI软件的画布都是一样的, 我并没有觉得某一家的画布特别好用
所以在我看来画布只是一种工作模式, 但是我要告诉大家是你必须要画布, 不然你的逻辑关系会很乱
所有的主流AI软件有画布的, 用我这套工作流完全够了, 不单独做推荐
二,提示词, 我用的提示词往往都非常的简单, 什么提示词堪比学术论文这种玩玩耿得了
我基本也就在评论区配合一下, 没那么简单, 实际上呢非常非常简单, 比如说这个镜头, 首次固定镜头女儿喝鸡
有母亲在骑电动车, 女儿抱紧母亲, 由关车门这个镜头, 直接给大家看, 真的都非常简单, 但不知道为什么AI给他生成的这个车拍照片是大S8, 真服了, 所以这里要告诉大家提示词不是越多越好, 精准的去表达这个状态就是最好的, 三,这里给大家讲一下误区, 很多小伙认为有了相同的工具就能做到相同的效果, 其实不是的, 我们不应该去优先先学AI工具, 你是需要有大量的审美积累的,
积累的培养自己做AI的导演思维
AI只是工具
所以我更推荐大家先学习分镜头的制作
和如何剪辑好故事
你先学好这个
后面再去接触美术
谁给大家上案例
比如爸爸在得知母亲五点过
就给他摘蔬菜以后
我们应该怎么样表现接下来的镜头
新手惯用的做法就是
人物把车开回去和母亲接触一下
说聊感人的口水话
手接过蔬菜
然后又放回车里
然后正前的人物特写镜头
发现没有这个镜头非常多
但全是脱了裤子放屁的镜头
设计是做减法的艺术
我是如何表达的
上一个镜头出现玉米蔬菜母亲在这掰
车出现
所有信息在一个镜头出现
然后你把后备箱一关
两个镜头观众就看明白了
这就是为什么很多人拿到Cdance2.0
这种非常顶尖的模型
做出来的还是一眼假的劣质内容
因为大家没有仔细研究基本功
工具只是缩短了影视质量的差距
但是讲好故事的差距其实还非常大
所以我这期分享的是一些
顶级商业篇的设计思维给到大家
这种内容放到肩商那开个课随便卖你2万
希望能够帮助到各位品牌方和创作者
AI时代大家创造能力其实是平权的
唯一拉开我们作品之间的差距从来都不是工具
而是你的想法
我是罐头
希望这期分享对你有帮助
如果你感兴趣可以点赞
后续会持续分享内容
接下来播放视频成片
我们下期节目再见
你们俩会撑多次哈
没有
每次拿一大堆都吃入碗
妈你自个儿留多次
就是妈
城里买都有
城门头卖不到我雷总
烤得好就了不起
脾气不小啊
你自己答应的事情做不到还说我
灵儿
把鸡汤喝了啊
妈我不想喝
开会呢
你这什么工作
怀孕都不能休息
喂妈
还没吃呢
再加班
嗯嗯
拜
爸爸
为啥子没了
来来给你熟菜了
现在拉炸还卖不到蔬菜吗
吃不完咋
来来早上五点过起来
宅里就卖不到
说了考好就给你
肯定就给你
跟你开个玩笑
还生气了
喂
外卖吗
我没点外卖
肯定是别人给你点的
电话地址都没错
喂 妈
我给你点的外卖收到了
我是说谁给我点的外卖
你是怎么学会的
你留意给我发的视频
照着学呗
一分钟教会你点外卖
最后一步最重要
请不吝点赞 订阅 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目